oh my gosh hi josh how are you
great lovely to see you again oh it's
really really lovely to see you
your family has been on the front lines
of the pandemic since it began
and i'm just so in awe of your entire
family
what has their journey been like what
has it been like for you
yeah first of all i agree and a huge
thank you to leah and michael you know i
i so
respect what those people are doing
partly because i've seen what
my family my sister is a coveted um
what she's called a pa physician's
assistant she went and
worked in a hospital in the very center
of the beginning of the pandemic in new
york city when things were
pretty rough to say the least and then
my father
is a emergency room physician who now is
doing
covet testing uh he's doing covet
vaccinations um
and my mother also as well she's a lot
like
those guys in in your earlier section
where she's on the side of the road with
cars pulling up on an
island um you know it was cool i spoke
to my sister the other day and
i said how you doing she said you know
for so long this thing has been so hard
and so
um you know just just physically
emotionally hard
she said but the last couple weeks i
started to feel this big transition
because she said things started to calm
down in her work
and she felt this shift and she felt the
hope that people are feeling um because
of the vaccination and you know my
family is adamant
all of them that the vaccination is a
you know a way out uh a a place that
just a place in an idea even in your
head that gives you some sense of
freedom
and my father and mother both now can
see their grandchildren because they've
been vaccinated so it's it's been a
really
beautiful thing to watch the work that
they're doing that
is what i'm so glad that you gifted us
with because
i want optimism that is grounded in
reality
and so hearing that that they're on the
front lines
they're the ones who are doing the work
and they feel the shift and we can
benefit from that wisdom
um and and have that realistic hope
thank you i it's invaluable for you
to share that with us thank you um
i know that something film in your
family home
when you were younger and it had a light
bulb go off will you tell me about that
my story is kind of beautiful we were
living on a small island in south
carolina
and i'd never been around movies i'd you
know i
i'd honestly never even seen a play um
at that point in my life and my uh
this little island for some reason this
little canadian film
company got snowed out of where they
were filming some scenes on a beach and
they needed a place that didn't have
terrible weather in the middle of winter
and
they came down and they rented the house
that we were living in as a production
office
and they filmed some scenes like you
know literally in front of the house in
the sand dunes
um and i was a eight nine year old boy
and i snuck out and i literally covered
myself and the the weeds you know the
the weeds that are in the sand um and
i i watched the scene like laying on the
beach i watched the scene between
two teenage lovers and uh i remember
just being
so i mean my heart was racing i was
scared of being caught
and it was magical at a level that
i i don't know if i've ever even felt
anything making movies as much as i've
sort of yearned for that first
high i guess um but i decided
in that moment to be an actor i love
that story
it's great to um find a sense of purpose
in all of our lives and i do think that
people are finding a sense of purpose in
ways that they did not know possible and
i see the evidence of it everywhere
and uh literally this show is here to
talk about that that's what i was going
to say you must be feeling that doing
the show right
literally the show wants to be
a platform to seek and find these
stories
out i love it all